the iron banker brothers founded in the
early days when bravo was still the
secret city
some of the people who were making money
and uh
have found some craft or some trade that
was doing well for them
joined together to form this bank to
lend money to
other bravosi initially uh
to help them to find businesses and all
that
and the the uh of course they were
pooling their own funds where do you
keep the funds you didn't
to these people men were rivals of each
other they didn't necessarily trust each
other
and they certainly didn't trust thieves
and
poor people and anyone who could come
and steal their money
so they found a an abandoned iron mine
and they only had one entrance
they put all the the funds down there
and
sealed it off with heavy gates iron bars
guards that were hired jointly and so
it's been called the iron bank of
braavos ever since
because it started in this abandoned
iron mine obviously they've
long since moved to far grander quarters
although that iron mine is still there
and used as a depository and as well as
being a historical artifact
separating the veil of aaron from the
riverlands is a
range of very rugged mountains the
mountains of the moon
there's a road through them but it's a
high
steep road for difficult
perilous in spots and of course those
mountains and the foothills around those
mountains
are where the hill tribes live
descendants of the first men the
original inhabitants of the veil who
were driven into the hills
by the andals who came conquering
centuries later
[Music]
there they live a very rough rugged
hardscrabble existence in these
mountains which are not
hospitable and they prey on people
coming through the mountains by this
single difficult
road and if you get past those you reach
the bloody gate
which is basically a fortified mountain
pass
where the veil of aaron opens up
so they've built uh essentially a
gateway
across the mountain pass and partly
in into the sides of the mountains
themselves hollowed it out
and this is defended by the knights of
the veil and it's largely to prevent the
hill tribes
from descending into the veil and
raiding and raping and killing and
carrying off plunder
you have to get past a bloody gate to do
that and the bloody gate is very strong
the way through the mountains is is
narrow and
steep and twisted and then you face this
daunting castle that can
fire things down on you and block your
path
and shoot at you with siege machinery or
arrows or spears or whatever have you
marine
is the biggest and most populous and
richest of the slaver cities
they do have some soldiers of their own
um
their own lords and nobles and princes
um you know are are trained somewhat in
the fashion of a
westerosi knight although with
you know some differences because it's a
different part of the world different
fighting styles
somewhat different weapons um they also
have great wealth
um but they're mostly depending on these
walls these walls are
you know large and thick
can't easily be breached